I wanted to let you go and experience more because if there's something better
for you,
I want that for you.
And vice versa.
Like if there's somebody better for me,
like I want you to want that for me.
Probably not.
Well
of course not.
Hi,
I'm
Shan Bu Dram,
but now Shannon Brady as a three weeks ago.
I am 33 years old and I'm a sex and relationship education,
right.
I'm Jan Brady and I am 27 and I record music.
We are married,
very newly married,
married for 23 days,
married for 23 days.
We actually met,
I used to promote like a lounge bar slash thing and um,
I invited a mutual friend of ours and she actually showed up with them,
but I don't really remember that night cause I was drinking a little bit.
I don't know why,
but this comes to mind like,
I'm not sure if he was doing that,
but when I think about when I first saw him,
he was like,
that dude was like moving through the crowd.
It's like,
that was my first impression.
I was like,
yeah,
this,
this dude has swag.
But unfortunately he never did come to dance with me.
So that's how we met.
But we didn't actually end up needing each other in person till a year after
that
she followed me on Instagram.
She sent me a message like,
let's hang out.
And then I was like,
all right,
we had to establish that,
you know,
her and I were just going to be,
am I allowed to cuss on here?
We're just going to be fuck buddies.
I Dunno.
We just kind of got each other on a,
on a very deep level,
very like honest.
In the beginning,
everything was up on the table.
First time I ever like got to like,
you know,
have a moment with you was inside my apartment,
which now that I think about that is a little frightening,
terrifying and knocked on the door.
He took an extra long time to answer and when you answered,
I was so relieved.
I was like,
you're real.
You're a real person.
I was actually in New York and I was spending time with another dude while I was
in New York.
I was there for work,
but like,
you know,
I have friends around town and stuff.
The next day I was reflecting on my way to the airport and I was like,
I had this great time with this dude in New York.
He's like,
we really vibe.
He's really cool.
I vibe with him.
And then I'm like,
I have this amazing connection with my friends with benefits.
Like we're just so in sync.
He understands me.
And so I tweeted out like I am learning so much about love without being an aero
slug in arrows.
Love is a romantic lab,
like a deeply devoted romantic love.
And Jared texts me and was like,
wait a second.
So it was our love,
not romantic.
I can't remember exactly what the tween is,
but had something to do with love.
And I remember just being like,
so wait,
we don't have this type of love.
And then I was like,
but do you love me?
And then he was like,
yeah,
I do.
And then I'm like,
Oh,
I love you too.
I didn't Google what arrows.
Arrows.
And so you're like,
wait,
you know what?
This means like,
yeah,
I know what it means.
I know what it means,
what it means.
We actually started calling our relationship open because I had somebody who I
from my past who I had unfinished feelings for that I hadn't seen a number of
years come back into my life and so I had to come to Jared and be like,
this isn't an unanswered question that if I don't get clarity on,
I think this is going to haunt me forever.
So like I need the opportunity to spend time with this person and for there not
to be any limits on that.
I wanted her to go and see what she felt about this person and choose me and
say,
you know what?
I want to be with you.
Just because we're open doesn't mean that we don't feel,
you know,
jealous for,
when,
when someone's going on a date or something like that,
when it has happened,
of course we feel jealous about it.
But I wanted to let you go and experience more because if there's something
better for you,
I want that for you.
And vice versa.
Like,
if there's somebody better for me,
like I want you to want that for me,
probably not.
But uh,
of course not.
But yeah,
no,
I,
that's the reason why I felt like you should go and experience that because it
would feel so much better to wake up to you every day knowing that you chose to
wake up and do it with me.
Even when you've done music videos with other girls,
right?
Like it's not 100% like completely like,
yeah,
go ahead.
Like do what you gotta do.
There's still that little thing.
But I actually in some ways enjoy that thing because it reminds me that like
this isn't a person that I own.
Like this is an individual that I have the privilege of sharing time with and I
should never take that for granted.
There was a time when we went on a hike and this was like at the time that we
were still kind of just having sex and we weren't really any things like
official yet.
And she had asked me to go with her to something or do something with her and I
was like,
I don't know about that because that's gonna put me in a different category.
And I was really trying to like,
I don't know,
slow it down and,
and,
and she was like,
well,
if you don't see anything here,
then what are we doing?
Like,
why are we,
you know,
going on dates then we should have just kept it on.
Just friends with benefits.
We ended up like,
not talking for a while because of that,
but I think it was the biggest argument,
um,
that we had
the day that I thought he was going to propose and he didn't.
I was on a show and it was like my last day of taping for the show,
he insisted on coming.
He's like,
I gotta be there early.
Like,
he just made this big thing where I was like,
oh,
and sure enough,
like nothing,
you know,
it's just like another day and it finished and you did,
it didn't happen.
And we got into the car and I didn't want to be upset because I'm like,
this is so stupid of me,
but we were starting to really create a life together and because of the fact as
well too that our relationship was titled Open.
They're just always so much negativity around our relationship and people
thinking we don't see each other in a serious light,
and to me,
solidifying our feelings with marriage would really just help to clear all that
up.
The engagement.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Know was talking about no makeup or breakout.
Oh Nah.
Yeah,
that wasn't bad.
I told him about the time we went on a hike.
Oh,
early on.
Yes.
I couldn't remember anything.
Oh yes.
That was it.
That was about it.
I think we come into relationships with an idea of how it's supposed to be.
We have a picture or a template that we want to like match up.
Like we're tracing almost,
we're not creating new art.
We're tracing what we've been told all these years and then that moment I'm
like,
oh,
rip that piece of paper up.
That's not what this is.
This is Jared.
This is a new person,
this is something different.
And maybe you don't just get to get surprised by an engagement.
Maybe you have to have a conversation and he's going to know your ring size and
advance and like,
that's okay.
It's still beautiful.
And when the moment came,
like you said,
it was still beautiful to me.
I see.
I see a couple of children,
I see a strong legacy and foundation.
Um,
and I just see,
I dunno,
I'm just so excited to grow old with you.
I see joy,
I see like limitless building.
I see businesses,
I see kids,
I see experiences.
Um,
but definitely the kids prior,
you know,
scares me the most.
I'm grateful to be dating a younger person for that reason because it's very
new.
Um,
but something that I definitely feel
I'm excited to get all then and just angry at the world together.
And what were you angry at?
The world?
So how about you be,
uh,
I think the,
you know,
the kiss thing is sensitive for me.
Uh,
I think it's,
it's,
it's scary for me.
It's like a new thing for me.
Um,
and when I look at you,
I'm like,
yes,
dad.
You know,
and I've never looked at someone before like that.
Ever since I met you,
I felt like I became a better person and I got to enjoy life a lot more.
You make me feel like spreading the news.
I to have said it better.
We just did our vows to so I'm like,
I tried to copy and paste those,
copy and paste everything I said,
Jared,
like it a shit.
This all,
you're the shit
I do.
Yo Jubilee Fam.
Thank you for watching Ian here,
Jean,
right?
They're rocking out to music.
We love making things that encourage people to dig deeper,
to be more vulnerable,
to live deeper.
Check out more videos there.
Subscribe here and we'll see you around next step.